people pay a hundred dollars for a steak
but they're not going to pay more than
for a chicken at jardiniere the
restaurant industry
we keep seven cents of every dollar wait
wait wait let me let me get this
straight so
you do a million in a month you're only
keeping 75 grand yep
if we don't see that 120 billion dollar
aid package go to restaurants we will
see
an extinction event of about 65 to 70
of restaurants that just won't make it
forget the 120 billion dollars
doesn't pass who takes the biggest hit
hospitality employment
is gonna keep crashing this is getting
worse it's not getting better
that's a pretty bold statement we just
made right but that's not a small
statement
i want my industry to survive but to do
so
i think it has to shut down the vaccine
is not going to be ready
how do we unpack that 120 billion
dollars to not say
we need to do another one 90 days later
90 days later think of the economic
dream all those people on unemployment
all those people without health
insurance were the second largest
industry in america second only to the
us government
too big to fail americans are dying by
the thousands
and we're all on a leaderless ship it's
fair to say you don't have a picture of
president trump on that wall
quarantine orders theater closures all
that kind of stuff
is gonna further dampen restaurant
spending how long do you think it's
gonna take that we get to three months
six months four months or you don't know
i do know i can tell you almost exactly
so my guest today is an american
culinary expert chef restaurateur
television personality radio personality
you may know him from his famous
show uh bizarre foods with andrew
zimmern i think it was on for 10
11 12 maybe 13 years i think from 2006
i want to say 2018 and he's back
february 2020 with msnbc
in february a show called what's eating
america and another show that's going to
be coming out
that's currently in production it's
called family dinner
we'll air on a forthcoming magnolia
network my guest today andrew zimmern
andrew how are you
i'm great how are you oh goodness so
what do you think about all these
restaurants going out of business
uh it's a cultural catastrophe it's an
economic catastrophe
it's a uh one of the saddest things that
i've ever seen
um because like so many of the issues
that are uh turning sideways and going
underwater in america right now
the vast majority of it was preventable
um
the leadership gap uh coming out of
washington dc
uh is uh responsible
for a lack of money flowing to states
and forget about the different acts that
are all trying to help various small
businesses and i do believe in the
what's now called the restaurants act
that's specifically designed to bolster
the
650 000 independent restaurants uh
around america by the way an industry
that is
second largest in america second only to
the u.s government
right a trillion dollar industry that
represents four percent of gdp so
definitely one
that is uh worth aiding
but the lack of money to the to the
states and municipalities
means that they can't spread money
around to allow for
restaurants that can't afford it to
begin
to reorganize both dining rooms
and most importantly kitchens back a
house and take care of workers
so that really any opening right now is
jeopardizing uh human life um
i do believe uh in the
uh the 239 scientists that sent a letter
to the who
that asked the body to recognize
airborne transmission of covid19
uh and the difference there is that
rather than just being
transmitted uh through our respiratory
systems the virus can linger in the air
indoors
uh infecting those nearby there's so
much we don't know about this
uh virus and so
restaurants have been pivoting one way
then pivoting another then pivoting
another way then pivoting another rules
are different everywhere
um and i think this is where the role in
if not
during a public health emergency then
then when does a government have a
national federal government have the
role
to step in and help backstop uh small
businesses
including independent restaurants so
yeah it's it's uh
i think it's it's horrific and quite
frankly
if we don't see the restaurants act
passed that's the one that congressman
blumenauer in the house
and uh wicker and cinema in the senate
have backed
if we don't see that 120 billion dollar
aid package go to restaurants we will
see
without a doubt an extinction event of
about 65 to 70
of restaurants that just won't make it
that's a pretty bold statement you just
made right there that's not a small
statement like that
no it's it's not and and it's the it's
actually the same statement that i've
made since the beginning of march
um and and i'm also not alone this is um
i'm not staring into a crystal ball this
isn't guesswork
um by their own admission
uh restaurateurs uh
statistically it they have come up with
a figure of about
80 percent of restaurants not being able
to reopen
now since that poll came out that was a
james beard foundation poll
that was quite extensive since that poll
came out
a lot of people have pivoted and found
other resources of income
and you know i bet if that poll went out
today i think
70 65 of them would say
without additional income uh or aid
we're not gonna be able to
uh survive so i think that number has
gone up a little bit
as people have realized that there are
other ways to make money with food
uh but you got to remember everyone is
locked into rents
they're locked into their insurance
packages their utilities packages
the uh perhaps payments on equipment um
loans to banks and investors so
they you can't continue to exist on 25
35 40
50 of income and at the same time
if they if restaurants aren't really
really cautious and this is where i
i it's not that i'm talking about two
sides of my mouth it's that
i want my industry to survive but to do
so
i think it has to shut down and the
reason is
is that if we develop hot spots in
restaurants
and if the public has a perception
because of some uh
less than responsible operators uh
ruining it for everyone which i'm seeing
right now here in minneapolis
i am worried that a hot spot develops
and then consumer demand drops because
they think restaurants in general are
problematic
when in fact it's any place people are
gathering is problematic
you know we just yesterday had the worst
uh day in terms of uh covet 19
statistics
in the entire history of the pandemic
this is getting worse
it's not getting better so it puzzles me
why we're talking about opening
businesses
and opening schools um it it almost
feels like a
genocidal uh betrayal to me
i mean we are americans are dying by the
thousands
every day in america and we have a we're
we're all on a leaderless ship i'm glad
you're not getting very political today
you're sticking to the business
i i sense the diplomatic side of you
today very impressive
well it's i mean look i've got to be
honest with you i mean it's it's both i
don't see things through
a lens that isn't civic and
you know i think civics touches
everything that we do
civic solutions often times
are political ones and i think that's
hard for folks to understand i think
people want to avoid talking about
politics i think they want to avoid
talking about subjects that make them
uncomfortable
it's one of the reasons why i made
what's eating america um i wanted to
talk about subjects that made people
uncomfortable but i also wanted people
to learn and be entertained
while they were being made uncomfortable
um
yeah i i i referred to it once in a
meeting as a roller coach
a roller coaster uh you know you're
scared it's going up
in the middle of the whole thing you're
saying i'll never do that again and you
get off and someone says how was it and
you say let's go again
i i think that it's important that we
have these discussions now more than
ever
so so let me ask you this because you
said a lot of different things there and
a lot of it had to do with leadership at
the top which is
directed towards trump and uh it's very
obvious you're
against businesses opening up due to
cases being up
uh uh uh your concern is if we do open
up it's gonna be disastrous so you want
120 billion dollars to go into the 650
000 restaurants open
that 80 of them don't shut down etc etc
great fine we know your position
here's my question for you uh 15 million
people work in a restaurant business
okay half of all adults at what point at
one point
worked at a restaurant i did obviously
you're in it
one third of americans first job was at
a restaurant
ten percent of nation's workforce is
employed at a restaurant this is not a
small number he said a trillion dollars
900 billion dollars to
uh be exact it's a very big number we're
talking about my question for you
becomes
who takes the biggest hit say that 120
billion dollars doesn't go out
forget the 120 billion dollars doesn't
pass it's not going up
andrew who takes the biggest hit
customers
servers owners food suppliers
uh america who ends up taking the
biggest hit in this industry
in this situation uh america does and
and i'll tell you why and i think that
owners uh
owners almost last and and let me talk
about that first
um there are a lot of owners
in the restaurant business that have
other businesses their corporate
restaurants chain restaurants
investment groups etc they're going to
find other projects
obviously the independent restaurant
owner the
you know you and i are partners i'm in
the kitchen you're in the front of the
house we put our life savings in
that was 15 years ago we've made money
we've raised kids we have a catering
business we got
we have a nice thing going we've got
lots of employees and we are
a stalwart in the community right
because remember restaurants are the
ones that are giving
everywhere right owners like us would be
hit hard
and then so would the rest of america
and let me explain that you cited a lot
of
uh really great statistics uh there that
are super super important for people to
remember
restaurants are also the number one
employer of returning citizens
coming out of jails and institutions
number one employer of single mothers
one of the top two employers of
immigrants
i mean the list goes on and on and on
as i said before the only industry
bigger than restaurants is the pen
is the us government so
what does that mean well unlike airlines
unlike cruise ship industries unlike
banks unlike
you know a lot of other businesses that
hold on to vast amounts of money
the restaurant industry averages
93 percent pass through essentially
we keep seven cents of every dollar and
of that seven
cents two and a half cents of every
dollar usually goes back into employee
subsidy programs like uh
paid sick leave to workers and and
things like that
as restaurants have begun to see the
importance of this so
when these restaurants go you know who
goes along with it
all of those wine makers all of those
clam
boats all the fishermen all the people
who are raising chickens and ducks that
have been sold into restaurants the
restaurant boom especially the
independent restaurant boom
of the last 20 years has created
communities
of producers suppliers the napkin
vendors i mean you name it
it affects it then there's the money
going out the backside
since we're the second largest employer
in america
collectively think of the economic drain
all those people on unemployment
all those people without health
insurance right
all of those people uh that are going to
put a strain
on different segments of our economy
the if if i am not an economist but the
ones that i speak to
when i start to have this conversation
with them
look at me and and basically tell me
that we're looking at an apocalyptic
event
now i'm not i'm not saying that i
believe a certain industry should go
out of business willingly but i'm just
going to draw a comparison
if an airline went bankrupt one of 20
you know domestic carriers in here
others would step into the void
right that's not the case with
restaurants right
when if if they're gonna go we're gonna
go in a
massive number because we're all in the
exact same
economic constraints and so you're
looking at something that will affect
main street usa
we pay so much in taxes remember cruise
ships got backstopped they don't they
pay like one and a half percent in
american taxes because all of them have
figured out a way to
to be offshore companies um
we collect liquor taxes pay sales taxes
we
we are the backbone of tourism nobody
goes to san francisco to get a sandwich
at panera you go to san francisco to eat
at the great restaurants or new york
when i travel to omaha i i i'm going and
i'm trying to figure out what the best
restaurant is there
so the the bottom line is there's so
many indus
industries co-dependent and woven within
it you're looking and
and while you cited this trillion dollar
industry
uh number it's really multiple trillions
of dollars when you add on hotels
hospitality
all the farm workers etc and you start
to get up to about 50 million people
uh that the food and hospitality system
employs and i'm afraid of the ripple
effect
for a hundred and twenty billion dollars
eight which i know sounds like a lot of
money
is a very small price to pay to avoid
the multiple trillion dollar problem
that we would face
if those restaurants went for you there
under
that was a very uh uh crystal clear on
the way you explained that so
the way it's going right now with cases
okay going up
and the level of trust in america is
right now not high if you look at the
tsa stats of travel
last year today we have 2.7 million
travelers today we have what 600
000 according to tsa reports that are
coming up we haven't recovered fully to
the 2.7
to 2.2 million the low we hit was 87 000
back in april
which we've come seven times that which
is great news to see progress
in a span of three months but here's my
question for you do you think
how long do you think it's gonna take
until we go back to 100 percent of
restaurants being open
and us being being able to go back to
friday nights go to a restaurant
oh it's not at fifty percent it's at a
hundred percent it's opened up how long
do you think it's gonna take till we get
there three months six months four
months or you don't know
uh i i do know uh i can tell you almost
exactly
um about nine months after a vaccine
that uh is effective to 85 percent of
the population
okay now now that might i mean look
we the great thing about capitalism
is that we have a global pandemic
if you and i were in any kind of medical
device or pharma company right now we
would be going
all guns trying to be the first one if
we had a
part of our business that could help
figure out a cure for this because
there's money to be made at it
right and uh i honestly think
because i'm very pro-business um
i honestly think that this is where
capitalism serves us so well
uh if we can come up with a vaccine
that works 85 percent of the time my
fear is we get one with side effects
that only works 65 or 70 percent of the
time
not that i wouldn't take that it
couldn't be improved upon
uh i certainly would but if we got one
that was effective 85 of
those uh vaccinated um
i'm i'm guessing that it's nine months
after that we go through
uh a cycle of seasons in america which
is
nine months um i think that you would
see
consumer demand return and that's really
the
that's really the core issue here when
does consumer demand
match its levels than it was before
right so you you mentioned travel i mean
well business has to start
picking up there right the vast majority
of uh people who are using the airlines
are business travelers right
top ten percent of customers are
responsible for like 60
of uh airline uh revenue something like
that
so but we're looking at business taking
on a different
shape these days i i have friends that
look uh work in uh you know
fortune 50 minnesota companies you know
like general mills and
and best buy and stuff like that uh 3m
every car get well yeah cargill every
single one of them
tells me that they're never going back
to work the way
they did before it's all going to be
flex time
or time at home because these companies
are figuring out a way
to get things done via a
tech that they were sort of afraid to do
before you know the
the virus forced everyone's hand to get
real familiar with how to run a zoom
meeting right
and guess what they figured out it
worked and they found out that even
though everyone is working 10
slower the savings on the real estate is
massive
so we'd rather have people have a better
lifestyle sure work at home
and we will uh we will soldier fourth
with restaurants you've got this
consumer demand
issue that is correlated to how
safe we feel being out in public amongst
each other
and that we feel the places that we're
going are custodians of the public
health
restaurants historically for the last
two generations have been
licensed entities in other words health
department has to license them there has
to be a licensed health sanitarian on
premise
at all times you usually have two or
three members of your staff take the
health department test
we we know what it takes and what it
means to serve
food and keep the public uh safe that
way
but we have to learn a whole new system
here when it comes to a respiratory
and what i believe is also uh an
airborne
uh transmission virus like uh covid19
and i think the last thing that i would
say to this um
and it's why i i link it to nine months
past a workable vaccine
um just over the last five or six days
and and
i'm on a whole bunch of committees here
in the state of minnesota and
actively engaged in talking with uh
health commissioners and and so on here
in our state as we're working through
some of the problems
and i'm on a lot of national committees
as well um
we're finding as the uh
pathologists are able to work on people
who have passed away from c19
that uh all organs are
damaged in people who've passed from
this disease it's not just fibroids in
the lungs
we also know that people who have
recovered especially young people have
recovered
uh not only have permanent lung damage
but we're
also looking at a neurological effect
uh reports out of the uh uk
with some really reliable uh studies
over there
are showing that there could be
long-term uh
effects on brain function associated
with people
who contract c19 perhaps
related to length of illness you know
some people get better in five weeks
some people are sick for three or four
months
the point being there's so much we don't
know about it
and and this affects all businesses
where the public gathers if you and i
own a shoe store we're selling online
eventually everyone learns to buy shoes
online
it's just it's eventually going to be
the way it happens i think what you're
talking about though is that pleasurable
aspect where you and i are grabbing a
couple friends and going out and
socializing and spending a night in a
restaurant
i've been addicted to that feeling since
i was 14 years old
if i think about it too much i'll start
to cry that
i got hooked as an early teen shucking
oysters in a clam house
in east hampton long island because the
the i i watched what
you know the the tray of icy briny
oysters
that i set down on the counter was taken
by a server to a table and you could see
how happy it made people
and it it flipped a switch inside me
that's never left it's probably even
stronger now
45 years later that people can't enjoy
that
feeling is killing me i can't wait to
get back to that friday night
i'm just worried that we we need
we need the type of leadership that says
to everyone
line up behind me we're marching over
that hill and we're not going to stop
we're going to spend
every dollar fight every battle until we
knock this thing back
and we're gonna help everybody those 350
some odd million americans
here today i mean you know i i
i had no favorite in the
you know in politics i haven't endorsed
a candidate or anything
yet but the mathematics that andrew yang
was talking about where we
give each american a certain amount of
dollars
now in light of the of the trillions of
dollars that
the government has given to corporations
and all of these different
uh backstopping acts passed by congress
boy oh boy if we had given that out to
actual citizens to start to
make it through this disease we might
have made a better choice
you know that is a form of an
endorsement but i'll tell you something
i'm talking about
uh uh you know the data of the
pathologist talking about in europe that
is showing signs and symptoms of
long-term effects and
you know what this could do to somebody
in different areas it's kind of the
argument of what some of the anti-vax
guys say that
you know the long-term effects of
vaccine has autism so there's a concern
written about driving the vaccine
of forcing people to take you without a
lot of testing especially all the
testing that they're going through
but the reason why i was asking this
question from you when you said
how long do you think it'll take until
we will go back to normal right how long
did it take until we go back to normal
so right now
you got 155 vaccines that are being
tested right now going against a
coronavirus 22 are in human trials right
now you heard nova backs yesterday which
is good news
novabax yesterday got a 1.6 billion
dollar funding from
the government not yesterday three days
ago and the stock went up 42
which is progress we're going in the
right direction and you're seeing other
people that are fighting to get into
that
conversation if you're saying nine
months after a vaccine comes out so
let's unpack that
the vaccine is not going to be ready for
people to take
probably they're saying fourth quarter
but let's just say q1
i think q1 is probably more conservative
and let's just say
february q1 little aggressive little
conservative will go right in the middle
okay
a year from when we first got oh
absolutely i'm with you
okay you're and you originally bought
you remember we said 12 to 18 months
well let's just say 12 months that's
aggressive february we got it fair
then you're saying nine months so that's
november okay
so if it's nine months november now
we're talking from today
july august september october november
4th
16 months till we go back to 100
uh i'm i'm my mindset is 2022
but we're going fourth quarter of uh
uh 2021. fair got 120 billion dollars
to get to restaurants in an industry
that's a
900 billion dollar trillion dollar
industry per year
you're going to have to do another one
90 days later
another one 90 days later another one 90
days later
so the the map you seem very uh one of
the things i enjoy about talking to you
is the fact that you've done a lot of
research about this and by the way you
sound like you should be sitting on a
committee
giving advice on restaurants and i'm
talking i'm talking from the white house
because
you know for someone like me i want to i
want to learn from you how do we unpack
that 120 billion dollars to not say
we need to do another one 90 days later
90 days later
great question um you know we
we spent a lot of time at the
independent restaurant coalition a group
that i co-founded
back in march you know about 60 or 70 of
us got together and said we need to
we need to change policy in washington
we need to have a voice
independent restaurants are going to be
left behind and we
we we banded together and we've grown
ever since
people can check out uh our uh
policy statements and the restaurant act
itself
i'm referring to the specific act that
uh congressman blumenauer introduced a
couple of weeks ago we have it on our
website
at saverestaurants.com we also have the
math on our website at
saverestaurants.com
the reason that we came up with that
number is that there are many
restaurants out there
corporate restaurants places that are
already
found a successful way to pivot that
wouldn't qualify
to take as much money as restaurants
that have been forced to close in
certain
areas in certain cities okay that's
number one
so it's not all restaurants getting the
same amount of money
number two uh
restaurants owned by women restaurants
uh owned by
people of color uh and indigenous
communities
get first bite at the apple because they
have the least amount of access to
the money from the banks right
statistically
so we're giving them first by the apple
we used a very
complex formula but essentially
it is uh a sort of
minimum amount to keep afloat for 18
months
minus your ppp minus your ppp if you
took it
is the amount of money that you get so
that
in that restaurant that you and i own we
can pay our rent
we can pay our utilities we can pay our
insurance so that we are
ready when people come back to work to
actually hire them when there are
customers to be there
if you and i happen to live in laramie
wyoming
where we have a successful restaurant
that's much different looking than
houston texas or miami florida right now
today in july of 2020
right um so in laramie we might have
customers we might have a parking lot uh
that we can serve
you know a hundred diners uh a night and
people willing to sit
uh socially distanced and wear masked
and
all the other stuff we may be able to
bring grills outside and grill steaks
and serve simple vegetables
and have people take advantage of it in
the camaraderie of of
small town usa and with a desire to
socialize and be with one another
um profits from those dollars would then
be subtracted from that so we
we have all the metrics in hand we know
how that 120 billion is gonna get spent
and we need to get to that money fast
before
more restaurants quit one of the issues
that um
we've had and i'm i'm sure you've seen
it every day
uh i see it a lot on social media i
follow
so many chefs and so many restaurants
just over the years every day i see
another three or four that i follow that
have said no i just can't do this
uh anymore and it it
it really shocks me right but i realize
that
you know restaurants that i'm involved
in
i own co-own or am a partner in four or
five different restaurants here in the
twin cities
uh two have yet to open
one has been doing uh takeout and
delivery the other one hasn't
uh we've opened patio on one because it
has one we have an open patio on another
because it doesn't have one
and we're waiting to see if we can open
up where we are going to open up if
we're allowed to at 50
here in minnesota because minnesota is
one of those states that's sort of at
even we've seen a small uptick uh in
numbers
uh but nothing that's taken off and our
governor has shown a lot of leadership
governor wall has really been amazing
but so many restaurants are folding
already
that we have a substantial number of
restaurants that statistical number of
you know 650 000 independent restaurants
that's out there
i i i have to imagine there's 7 500 000
of them that
aren't even open at all and never will
open as of right now
so that number has gone down in terms of
who needs
the money i think what's really hurting
restaurants and what we have to remember
is a whole
network of effects that we're also
trying to deal with
number one indoor dining in many cities
could be a very long way off
right because it's different everywhere
and we have this airborne transmission
issue
quarantine orders travel restrictions
theater closures you know movie i'm
talking not talking broadway you know
movie all that kind of stuff
is going to further dampen restaurant
spending right people
aren't going to be out and about in big
major metros where the majority of
people are majority of restaurants in
america
uh are um the
outdoor dining delivery and takeout
business
isn't a panacea for the industry we
mentioned it before in a long list of
things
but it doesn't make up for i mean if
you're a if you're a business that's
only taking seven and a half percent
to the bottom line you've got to be at
capacity right you've got to be back at
those pre-covered numbers
and and look many restaurants we haven't
even talked about this side
but you know it's true many restaurants
were very fragile and brittle
to begin with when i started out in this
business
i asked my godfather frank granit guy
that owned a bunch of restaurants and
got me jobs when i was 14 15 16
restaurants i wanted to learn from him
and he had a three-month prudent reserve
at every restaurant
you know the restaurants that i'm
involved in i mean
and i'm talking about really successful
ones there's no three and a half month
prudent reserve
no one has no one has one wait wait wait
let me let me get this straight so
you said seven and a half percent is
that is that even even a profit that's
like you yep
and 75
restaurants are extremely brittle and
extremely fragile and the reason
the reason is this um and i'm talking
about independent restaurants
you can't you know the fair wage
uh sorry the uh fair trade coffee
uh movement that causes big coffee boom
right
everyone was buying 75 cup of coffees at
the local corner store
and then all of a sudden starbucks and
all these coffee shops started you know
and now we all drink a five dollar cup
of coffee right and one of the reasons
that we do is that everyone really got
involved on the social justice side of
this which was the fair trade program
for beans
right let's help these small communities
of farmers on these fincas
all over throughout the coffee growing
region by paying
a fair trade price for the beans so that
these villages
could actually succeed not just as a
subsistence farmer
but as a successful farmer so that their
communities could have schools and a
clinic
and all the rest that kind of stuff
right but we're lagging behind that in
the food business
i have a friend tracy desjardins one of
the most famous chefs in the world
michelin starred restaurant jardiniere
in san francisco her flagship restaurant
she closed it last fall i was
interviewing her on a panel
i said why did you close she says well
you know we weren't making all that much
money
and then at three three years ago
i i really felt that i wanted to take a
lot of the profits that we had
even though it wasn't much and put it
into
uh programs for my employees number one
because i wanted to take care of them
right like paid sick leave and stuff
like that uh
a bonus program etc she said but also
because the economy was getting better
and better and better and better
unemployment was dropping dropping
dropping
employee retention was getting harder
and harder and harder
and rent was going up right we know you
know i don't have to tell you about
rent issues in san francisco new york
seattle where everything is through the
roof
employees are traveling an hour and a
half into work to restaurants in the
city and they're just saying it's
killing them they're not making enough
money
so she decided that she was going to
raise her prices and actually
charge enough money so that it was
profitable so
when she opened she said her half roast
chicken
a really nice roast chicken by the way
was like 17
her costs had gone up over 25 years by x
number of hundreds of percentage points
right
rent payroll insurance all the rest that
25 years she was in business
so you can imagine those costs going up
but the cost of her chicken she still
couldn't charge
more than 24 she found that the minute
she tried to go up above
despite the fact that to put the chicken
on the plate and all the costs and you
know
the right fare cost for that chicken was
like 32
no one's gonna spend 32 for a half a
chicken right
you'll do it people pay a hundred
dollars for a steak because they would
this special occasion at a steakhouse
but they're not gonna pay more than
24 for a chicken at jardiniere and so
we have artificially deflated food
uh prices all across our restaurant
system you know it's that whole dollar
menu
uh mentality that has artificially de
brought down
the cost of food we're addicted to steak
in the supermarket being a certain size
and a certain color and have a certain
that the muscle has to have a certain
size to it
and we're not going to pay more than
9.99 a pound it
is it's it's causing problems in farming
it's causing problems in restaurants
um and you can't make a living
on outdoor dining on
to go and to take out and deliver it
just it just
doesn't work not in the not with the
lease that you and i have
in our uh pretend restaurant and with
our cost now
if we close that down and we move down
the street
to a place that's very undesirable from
a storefront
point of view but we can do all the take
out and community kitchen
and delivery from there because we're
not seating customers then you and i
have come up with a different business
model right
and that's part of the issue uh as well
um
restaurants have to dig themselves out
of a rental i mean
the figures that i saw from new york
city from
roar was that in new york 73 percent of
landlords
did not waive rent in june
and 80 of new york restaurants
did not pay their full rent in june
according to the surveys that rohr did
in the hospitality alliance did
i mean that that's the these the kind of
statistics that show you how fragile and
brittle the industry is
and and you have to remember the ppp aid
was only designed to be temporary right
so we need something with a little more
heft uh to it uh like the restaurant
stabilization bill that uh blumenhour
and wicker proposed in the house and
senate respectively
and we began this line of questioning by
talking about who suffers
hospitality employment in general
is going to keep crashing but i do think
as i said it's the american people who
are going to be the big losers
because main street usa those those
taxes that go to
keep the roads paved put books on school
uh
desks um people don't understand how big
the collective industry is and even
statewide
like here in minnesota our collective
restaurants that put a billion dollars
into our state's economy
um you know that number is down to 200
million
that's a huge huge uh
problem for our state lawmakers in terms
of meeting budgets
again we're the second largest industry
in america second only to the u.s
government
too big to fail too big to fail of an
industry
there's uh there's about one on your
website it's a yellow and blue color uh
we're gonna put the link below for
others to go see the whole thing about
uh what you're doing with your uh
restaurants but uh you know you said a
lot there 73
in new york didn't wave this is the
owners didn't waive
rent eighty percent didn't pay which is
a wash because
whether you wave or not i don't have the
money to pay you so what do you mean
you're not going to waive it i don't
have anything
yeah yep customers coming in so you want
me to go out of business they're not
gonna get me for two years
now you got an empty place sitting
there's a commercial industry he's
taking a massive hit
huge you're explaining 50 million people
tied to the restaurant
that makes a lot of sense let me let me
ask you how close are you
or who is the most close person right
now working to the trump administration
that's showing these types of stats
where they're sitting there saying you
know this makes a lot of sense we have
to save the restaurant business
who is the main voice that's
spearheading that message to them
great question um about four or
five weeks ago kudlow mnuchin
vice president pence president trump
jared kushner
ivanka trump invited a group of
restaurant leaders
into the white house for a lengthy
meeting i think
there were 12 invited guests three of
them
uh were co-founding members of our
independent restaurant coalition from
save restaurants.com
so we actually had a seat at the table
there
there were several other uh restaurant
industry
types there people from big
big giant chains all the way down to
single operators but we got to get our
message uh
across and it was because of that
meeting
uh that we were able to not only get
uh it was because of that meeting that
representative
dean phillips of minnesota and chip roy
republican of texas
were able to introduce the act that was
the ppp fix that extended it from eight
weeks to 24 weeks
right uh and the reason that the
president signed that bill
uh was uh after it passed
was because of that meeting he heard
what he needed to hear
at that meeting and turned to secretary
mnuchin
and others and said you think i should
do this and they were like well this is
a you know
we were building a plane in in mid-air
and ppp does have some issues and
you know we want to be able to extend
the runway we don't have to give any
more money we're just extending the
runway of forgiveness
and reorganizing the uh the terms of
those
forgivable loans right to have it make
more sense
not just for restaurants by the way but
for small businesses all across america
one of the problems was the length of
loan the other problem was that it was
uh payroll 25 uh
utilities rent and other costs and it
went to 60 40
and from eight weeks to 24 weeks um but
we had a seat at that table
and we got a chance to talk to the
secretaries and to the vice president
uh and for a little bit to the president
about
the uh restaurant stabilization act
so i have i have cautious optimism but i
still have
optimism and i look i'm not going to lie
to you anyone had all anyone has to do
is look at my work on msnbc
look at my social media feeds and and i
think everybody understands that i'm
quite left of center uh i'm not quite on
karl marx's left knee but i'm sort of on
his
right knee while he's reading me a book
that was a joke
uh but i'm definitely i i am definitely
uh left of center the
uh the and and my point is is that you
know
at his core president trump's business
advisors
understand that that 120 billion dollars
that we're asking for
is very small compared to what would
happen
if i mean just the employees on
on unemployment for another six months
dwarfs that number right so it's not can
we afford the 120 billion
we definitely can't afford not to give
out the 120 billion
so are you full-on communist or would
you say you're socialist right before
communists because
i'm neither i was i was i was making a
joke i'm i'm
very socially progressive i'm i'm good
oh very nice
it was very small marx's communist
manifesto
these uh these men are sitting here in a
ball they're debating those two books so
i love that
i love that um i'm def i mean look i am
uh i am someone who is a uh very
civic-minded and political person i've
been
involved in a lot of social justice
activism since my parents got me
involved as a young child in the 60s
um growing up in new york in a uh
in a very progressive family um
and you know i believe it's my civic
responsibility
uh to be an active voice and probably
more importantly
um when my tv career took off um
i felt that if you have a platform and
you don't do something good
with it um you have
you've left a hole in the ground that
can't be filled
somewhere else and um you know
i i was determined to devote
25 of my time and 25 of my money
uh to social justice causes that i
believed in
and i started doing a lot of board work
and i started to get involved in a lot
of national and international programs
people can go to my website
andrewzemran.com and click on our
resources and our partners page
to see the type of groups i'm involved
in but you know i'm on the board of
services for the underserved in new york
uh the irc not the independent
restaurant coalition the international
rescue committee that einstein founded
in 1939
refugee uh do a lot of refugee work
work with a lot of organizations i'm on
a lot of boards i try to work
on homelessness and hunger and addiction
issues
and and the like and it it's really been
in the last three years
as i've seen the work that my parents
undertook
for a lifetime away from their
businesses
uh the work that so many people have
done for
uh on the social justice side and to
promote equality in america for everyone
and seeing that under attack definitely
got me more civically involved and
definitely got me more politically
involved
and i made a conscious choice uh
that while you know my new show family
dinner on magnolia
is definitely a a trickly sweet
piece of entertainment um but it's about
connecting with families over food
something that i believe
does have healing properties and i
wanted america to see
what it looked like for families to
spend more time together eating because
i believe that
we'd be better off as a nation if we all
spend a little more time together over a
table of food
but by that same token i'm also making a
show called what's eating in america at
msnbc
which is very civic oriented which is
very issue oriented uh which does not
pull any punches and we explore
everything from
voter suppression to climate change to
food and wellness and
addiction etc well so again like i asked
you earlier to confirm it's very
important it's fair to say you don't
have a picture of president trump on
that wall anywhere else right
that that that would be that would be
correct
um i have i have pictures of joe namath
uh during his most anarchy plagued years
uh the new york jets when he was the
owner of a famous bar in new york called
bachelor's three
and he's in the he signed it to me also
it's it's uh
he's in the fur coat the mink coat
sitting on the bench with the sunglasses
the the broadway joe here with the long
hair you know
my heroes uh are uh
are definitely not members of this
administration very cool all good thank
you for
sharing that and i think it's fair to
say that joe namath has probably partied
harder than you and i combined
although i don't know your background or
party and i know joe's a hardcore party
some lighthearted questions we covered a
lot of politics we covered a lot of
different business stuff
i'm just curious you know for somebody
who loves caviar what is the best
kind of caviar for me to look for if you
were to say let me educate you on caviar
for two minutes what could you educate
me on about caviar i grew up in iran
i lived there for 10 years lived at a
refugee camp in germany for two years i
grew up by uh
my family owned the place by bandar
pahlavi back in the days which was by
caspian sea
and the caviar there was delicious but
i'm curious to hear your feedback and
thoughts on caviar
damn it jesus well the first thing is
that why aren't we standing together
somewhere in a kitchen
socially distanced cooking together what
i would refer to generically because
it's a broader
geographic footprint of persian cuisine
at the
at the you know at the height of
uh that culture's influence um
in central asia and the middle and what
is now the levant in central asia
um i'm not sure there's a there's a a
broader and wider cuisine
one of the one of the world's truly
great great
cuisines and i love persian food i don't
have to educate you about a caviar i'm
sure you know a lot about it i often
tell people
it's whatever you think tastes good
let's start there
these are salted fish eggs not everyone
has the
flavor for it but if you do um i do try
to take people
away from lump fish row and other things
that are sort of like pretend
caviars but then the issue that gets
raised is
uh the cost and what's uh
you know i'm hoping as more and it's
part of the reason why i
actually promote what caviar eating that
i do not to
pat myself in the back or to you know uh
claim some sort of elitist uh
position it's just that my hope is since
it's one of my favorite foods
that we can invest more in aquaculture
because every year the
the more companies that get involved in
this stuff the lower the price
uh drops now the caviar industry is
like many other food industries
boomed over the last 10 years uh whether
it's
farm sturgeon farms in taiwan that i
visited um
or ones in florida i mean i've told
stories about caviar production
aquaculture caviar production in six or
seven different countries around the
world over the course of the last 15
years
but now they have no one to sell to
because restaurants are closed
um which is very very sad
i will tell you that while uh
the great true malasal
low salt beluga caviar etc whatever your
size preference is
something firm something that really
pops in the mouth something that has a
beautiful balance of salinity
while for some people they automatically
assume that costs a lot
i did a story in oklahoma about
five years ago on the oklahoma
department of natural resources
and they were trying to they have a wild
paddlefish
population there oklahoma and missouri
the only states in america where wild
paddlefish exist
and they can be fished you get a license
and you're allowed to pull
x number of fish out of the water but
the paddlefish in oklahoma
actually go to go through two egg laying
seasons right so a lot of these
farm fishermen would open up their fish
and fillet them
and paddle fish is quite delicious and
uh magically they found that people were
throwing away these
five six pounds of roe that was inside
the wild paddlefish
well the department of natural resources
guys had seen
one of my older shows from 10 years ago
in missouri where i was actually with
fishermen
fishing the paddlefish and i actually
made homemade caviar by
salting the eggs and then i took whole
sets of it and much of the same way we
fry
other sets of egg row sliced it in
pieces
lightly floured it fried it served it
with scrambled eggs and toast and butter
it's delicious just fry it medium rare
the same way you would shad row in the
in maryland
and uh or smoked cod row in ireland
and england and scotland and
these oklahoma dnr guys had seen the
missouri show they sent one of their own
to caviar school
and now they make wild paddlefish caviar
from oklahoma
that is so blank and delicious 99
of the caviar in my pictures you can see
me making reference to it i think you go
to the oklahoma dnr
uh page and make your way to it um
it's very inexpensive it's really good
and all the money
that from the caviar program goes to
support the
uh water systems in the state parks
in the state of oklahoma so if you
google wild
oklahoma paddlefish caviar it'll
probably take you
right to uh the website where you can
order it
wild oklahoma paddlefish
caviar caviar i'm gonna look it up and
i'm going to order it and
i've i've sent it to i mean they're
chefs i've i've been
i i have no financial stake in this
there's no this is not a sponsored thing
at all i just happen to love this
story so much and all the money goes to
help the
the streams and rivers and forests in
oklahoma
and so one of the amazing things i've
turned all my chef friends onto it in
blind tastings and they'll go wow
that's pretty good i mean it's it's i i
can tell this
you know we're not talking about you
know primo but we're talking about
something that's a rock solid b
plus then i tell them what it is then i
tell them the price
and they lose their minds there's more
restaurants now buying and selling this
stuff because i've just been bringing it
to food festivals doing it
at dinners and all the rest of it uh
it's very inexpensive
as in uh single digit
hundreds of dollars for a kilo
wow and it's delicious the article here
april 12
2016 how oklahoma cornered the market
in caviar national geographic there you
go
yes i'm gonna look that up so that's
good to know now here's the other thing
i've eaten at a lot of different
restaurants worldwide i'm a foodie
myself i love great food
you know whether it's from a
hole-in-the-wall sushi spot where the
chef the owner makes it and you can
trust his work
to a high-end restaurants and monica
louis the 15th or a
nice restaurant hole in the wall la
vitrola and cartagena colombia to all
these other places you've been all over
the world
by the way i know i know both i've dined
in both of those last two restaurants
in monte carlo i went there when alandu
cass was a young chef
and arguably the best chef in the world
and he had just
gotten three stars for two different
restaurants
i was a young cook this was in the 80s i
was stashing
in a restaurant in paris that alas
cinderella was the chef at
called larc estrada alas cinderella's
first michelin 3 star
and a whole bunch of us drove down and
for three days we showed up at 5 30 or 6
o'clock when they opened
to see if there was a table in our
crappy
blazers you know and i mean you know
young grubby cooks
and it changed my life that meal i
i had never seen and it was the first
time and now it's
now it happens more frequently i can
name up
25 restaurants in america to do it but
at the time
in 1982 83 84
i had never seen butter churned
in a kitchen and the bread baked in the
kitchen
both according to the reservation chart
they were churning butter multiple times
a day so the butter was never
refrigerated at the louis cass
in monte carlo the build-up
under the cap of the churning machine
was actually whipped way from the
separation
right they would take that way and they
would constantly
every hour scrape off a few tablespoons
and that's what they would use
to delicately saute use it like a
cuisine just to glaze
root vegetables for one of the lamb
dishes
when you think of the lengths that
restaurant was going to
just with that simplest of ingredients
butter
you get and bread you get an idea of
what i had
never had an experience like that and it
changed my food life
uh forever you know it's crazy you said
that you said
you you went there when the when the the
the chef who went
i read his article that he went at 28
years old from a one star to two star to
a three star
in three years and he was like the
legendary one uh worldwide that
everybody and by the way they still do
the butter it's in display you see the
show when they're doing it when you go
into the place oh do they do they do
that now
because before it was hidden away in the
kitchen in the middle it's
really what you were telling me i was
watching and i'm like what are they
doing over there
and then they come and they tell you
about it so you eloquently explain that
but out of all the places you've been
out of all the places you've been
what's your number one where you say
if money is not an issue if i want to
take my friends if i want to go to a
place and sit down and join with my
number one
is dot dot dot what is that place for
you
oh my gosh um
that's a very difficult question to
answer and i would answer it differently
today than i did a couple years ago
a couple years ago i might have
said something like you know let's go
and do the vegetarian tasting menu at
arpeggio in paris
let's go to one of the three star
michelin
uh restaurants in tokyo right let
let's go and really celebrate in the in
the private room
at you know uh a linea and tell them to
really put
on the feed bag for us right i mean just
to have that over the top experience
i love that kind of dining i truly do
because i love seeing what a chef can do
that kind of chef
at the peak of his
powers with ingredients the
transformational
things that they do with food the the
techniques that are going to be used 30
years later once it
trickles down to you know home cooking
but i think what's most what's notable
and powerful for me
are the places where i can share
more food with more people on the island
of palawan
in the philippines there's a
a bunch of floating restaurants you you
some are at the end of a dock they've
built a rickety dock
half mile out into the water there's i i
wrote about one in in my first book you
know a place where i can go
where the fishermen come in and they
they they lift the
fish and the shellfish and the mollusks
up into the center of the restaurant
through a big hole cut in the middle of
it
the restaurant is on stilts in the water
where you can watch the sun go down
where you're sitting on the water
where the bananas for frozen banana
drinks are cut from a giant
ripe banana plant that was tree ripened
that's sitting by the bar
where the limes are grown in the
backyard of someone's house and picked
and brought in
where everything is so fresh and so
simple and it's really a matter of
whether you want your
fish or shellfish you know grilled raw
or sauteed that's the only way we do it
pick your poison those the kind of
places that really thrill me the most it
has as much to do with location
and simplicity of food um as it does
uh with the quality of what's being
cooked because i think the quality now
means something different to me
um i've seen all the pyrotechnics i've
seen all the fancy stuff um
you know you talked about cartagena
in medellin there's uh
a poll carbon you know charcoal roasted
chicken is
what's eaten every street has a
different pile carbon
place but there are a couple that do it
a lot better than the others
right you know give me a good plug
carbon
place and a lot of really cold frosty
root beer
and 30 of my closest friends and let us
just sit there for hours and get
messy with our fingers eating poyo
carbone
going out into the street and buying a
sugar cane juice with lime and mint
crushed with it
i'm happy as a clam there last night i
shooting an episode of family dinner i i
was eating with the nigerian family
and uh they they did a version of
burning meat on skewers something that
all over africa you go into
neighborhoods and it's just
people build a fire throw a grill on top
of it and you can actually pick your cut
typically the animal is there being
butchered on the back table and you can
point and say i want a little
shoulder i want a little luxury cut
because everything costs a different
price
right they they know the luxury cuts are
more expensive than cuts from the
the leg or the tendon or the neck or the
cheek um
and you know you sit there and you order
it same thing in the
you know jamal fana in marrakech you
know in the sukk there
where with lamb it's the same you order
the meshui and they pull a little bit
from different parts of the animal and
they put it on a piece of newspaper and
they spill a little bit of
cumin chili and salt mixture on the
plate for you to season your own lamb
with
and you eat it with your fingers if you
want bread they send a kid
around the corner to the bread place and
he comes back with that and some
hot or cold mint tea i'd rather eat in a
place like that
almost if if you said andrew
lets you and i go to one place for
dinner tonight
anywhere in the world it might be
to some of the markets that i've been to
in small villages jungle markets in the
vietnamese countryside where
spring rolls and grilled fish and shrimp
salads and just just
the food that you just you want to just
keep eating for the rest of your life
you pinch yourself it's so good as being
made
fresh i remember being in uh isaan
thailand up in the north on the uh
laotian border just about
30 miles from vientiane but about five
eight miles in from the
laotian border and i was on a farm
and they told me that they were gonna
make uh a shrimp salad a drunken shrimp
salad for dinner
and i knew that you know you take the
small shrimp and they're live
and you drown them in rice wine and then
you mix it with toasted rice powder and
chili and ginger and garlic and fish
sauce and sugar and
mint and cilantro and crushed peanuts
and tomatoes
uh and you have this just fantastic
shrimp salad it's one of my
favorite dishes uh in the vietnamese
vietnamese culinary cannon
and grandma went down to the river with
her net and started taking these
freshwater shrimp
out of the out of the river
i don't think i'd eaten anything that
good you know i would put that dish
up against anything that i've eaten
anywhere on planet earth
right um food is not just about
the expense you know that's why the
caviar conversation used to make me
uncomfortable
um and i have it freely with people
where i have the opportunity to explain
it
because the fact of the matter is is
that the food that i find
is the most precious is the stuff that's
only available on what i call the last
stop on the subway
the further away you have to go to get
it the more valuable it is
a year ago if you and i want to have a
great meal in new york right
i mean between the two of us we can call
up friends we can get into any
restaurant we want as a deuce right
we'll eat at the bar
we'll have an amazing meal the chef will
throw all kinds of free stuff
at it the bartender will keep us happy
and we're gonna have a good time you and
i
any restaurant but what we can't do is
be out in a village in
botswana with a big fat yellow african
moon
rising up over the aha hills while a
goat is slowly roasting over the fire
while people are playing the same music
that their ancestors played for 40 000
years
we can't how do we we can't buy that
that's the precious experience that
i got to have for 14 years on the road
making bizarre foods and other shows
um that i miss that was an amazing era
in my life to be able to have all those
experiences and know what that feels
like
and by the way have that same meal but
have it be moose
with the athabascan tribe while it's 30
degrees below zero in front of a bonfire
while they're white they're spearing
white fish on the very last night of the
season
before the river freezes for good i mean
that's
that's the that's where i'd want to take
you and my friends
is to eat that because the look on your
face
at the fancy restaurant in paris would
be
holy crap this is amazing i take you
up to at the baskin country and you're
like you're in so much clothing you
can't move and someone puts boiled white
fish right out of the river
in your face by the way that you speared
and risked your life because if you fall
in the water you're dead
it's so cold they can't get you to the
fire fast enough
they lose a couple of people every
season usually
elderly folks who've been drinking too
much you
really will enjoy that white fish
because
the environment in which we're consuming
it together
is conducive to a real human connection
that i don't think you necessarily get
in a fancy restaurant let me tell you uh
uh
you know i wonder how you talk dirty to
the ladies because
your last seven minutes of whatever you
do with food i am so hungry right now
i can't wait to go eat at any of those
places but it's crazy you're saying this
because it took me back to uh
a time i went to guatemala back in 2005
and we were driving
in guatemala guatemala is not known as a
rich place and then you go to this place
and it's called
it's amazing and they say well this is a
place where european people
live i'm like european people live in
guatemala we have puerto varios
and we went to this place hole in a
while you ate but they brought the
lobster they brought the food
from the best dish i ever had look i've
really enjoyed the conversation with you
and it's interesting to hear a story of
somebody who had 14 years old gets
inspired by oysters and a man who's born
on 4th of july
who likes capitalism because improves
the restaurant business
what would your final thoughts be to
small business owners who own
restaurants and folks who are in
restaurant business right now who are
little ward if you have final words
final thoughts for them what would you
say to them
um food people despite the gloom and
doom that i talked about before
i do believe there's going to be a
stabilization act passed but more
importantly
the most creative the most
free thinking the most giving sharing
coolest people in the world are food
people
uh with apologies for everyone else out
there
i've been around food people my whole
life they have the biggest hearts
they're the they they have pivoted three
or four times already since february
i think i think the the
the higher power that i believe in puts
the large burdens on the shoulders of
people that can handle it
and while this has been a horrific
moment for restaurants
it's also been a very freeing one our
industry was very brittle and fragile
and it was also had a lot of inequity in
it
uh i mean people forget three years ago
the the metoo movement that
you know rampaged through our industry
um the the fact that we've mistreated
you know
people of color working in our kitchens
and
depressed prices and not paid a fair
wage and
not been able to offer benefits to these
workers
and and dignified the back of the house
side of the profession from the
dishwasher to the porter
to the prep cook right we've we've
deified the chef
right we've professionalized the server
and the mixologist we don't even call
them bartenders anymore
but we have an opportunity now i would
have liked to have take our house apart
brick by brick
before we rebuilt it instead someone
burnt it to the ground
covered 19 burnt it to the ground we
would be stupid to rebuild it in the
same
format that we did before i think there
are people restaurateurs
food people all over this country
figuring out a better
smarter way i think we will come out of
this we will look back
20 years from now on a 10-year period
post coveted 19 that we will call the
golden age of restaurants because we
will have figured out a way
both to honor the food the farmer the
planter the picker
the cook we will be able to honor every
single person
equitably along that whole food chain
and i think we're going to be
better off for it as a society and i
think food people will drive that
decision-making
i mean one creative idea that you've
seen in the last few months in the
restaurant business that other
restaurant businesses can implement
one creative idea uh gather your best
[Music]
purveyors and package their goods
in a food box that goes to families
now some people have done it based
around uh there's a local restaurant
here called grand cafe which sold you
four meals for four people
for x number of dollars with everything
labeled and all the rest of that
uh for folks that wanted to cook a
little more adventurous adventurously at
home
other people like dan barber up at blue
hill at stone barns has just accumulated
cheese from his cheese people
meat from his meat people seafood from a
seafood people charcuterie from his
charcuterie people
you know tomatoes from his tomato people
and put them in a big box and said every
week here and get this box for x number
of hundreds of dollars
you don't have to go to the supermarket
we're putting in a little bit of
everything for you
i think that's an area beyond takeout
and delivery
that is really really really important a
lot of people in america
not all but a lot would like to be
eating cleaner healthier food
less of it higher quality and i think
restaurants can provide that for their
uh neighbors and communities
andrew thank you so much for being a
guest folks we're going to put the link
below of uh
what he's spearheading right now to go
visit and if you support it he can
support it as well appreciate you for
being a guest on valley team and i
really enjoyed the time with you
i loved having a real conversation with
somebody who
asked really provocative questions and
loves my subject matter as much as i do
and for anyone interested we have a lot
of information at andrew zimmern.com
not only uh issues of the day and
resources
but incredible uh charities to support
as well as
thousands and thousands of videos and
recipes and all that
kind of stuff it's a fun award-winning
website i'm really proud of the people
here in my group that put it together
so please go visit andrew zimmern.com
we'll put
both the links below andrew again thank
you so much for your time i enjoyed it
i appreciate it thank you my friend i
got to tell you i went into this
interview thinking we're going to go
into the restaurant direction he went
purely politics right off the bat and
was incredible i mean i learned a lot
and i enjoyed this interview
to know what the restaurant industry is
really experiencing the 50 million
people that are somehow someway directly
connected to the restaurant business was
mind-boggling and if you enjoyed this
interview i think you would also enjoy
sit down and i had with chad solomon
who's a cattle rancher
and he broke down the effects of what's
happening to the meat industry
from it from a perspective that you and
if we're not in that industry we don't
understand it got one and a half million
views
in the first week because people really
wanted to know where is the meat made
out of and
is it important should we know where the
meat is made out of so if you've not
watched it go ahead and click over here
to watch that interview
a very very interesting interview and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye